Hey YouTubers, it's Charlie.
So James Gunn has been dropping all kinds
of details Guardians Of The Galaxy 2 including
the script,
what's in the movie, what's not in the movie
So this is going to be a breakdown of that
I've also got details at the end of the video
about the new weekly DC and Marvel giveaways
I'll be doing all summer long.
Yay!
Everybody likes free stuff.
So what James Gunn is talking about is he
finished the first draft of Guardians of the
Galaxy 2 you and he's been passing it around
to the people Marvel as well as some of the
actors.
Chris Pratt said it made him cry, but he was
just talking about the pitch, he wasn't talking
about the actual script.
He hasn't read the script yet.
James Gunn is one of those directors that's
really open about their process and day-to-day
stuff.
He's really big on snapchat too of all places,
which I think is funny.
That script that he just finished took him
about 48 days to finish, which is pretty quick
for a movie that big.
Sometimes it can be a little easier to break
Sequels just because you've already created
the universe of the film.
The first Guardians film was all about creating
the universe.
The treatment for the film which came before
the script took him almost like nine months
though.
The difference between that and the script
is that the treatment is is basically like
a breakdown of all the plot points and the
characters.
It's like the bones of the script that you
used to sell the film to executives at Marvel.
Like this is how the film is going to go,
these are the character beats, everything
including the actual dialogue in the stage
direction.
Once you know the characters are going to
do, then you decide what they're going to
say.
That's probably why it was easier for him
to write the script, it just because he already
knows what those characters are thinking in
all their heads.
If you already know that they're thinking,
you probably know what they're going to say
to each other.
Okay, 1st awesome thing: James Gunn is not
beholden to the same tie-ins as the other
Marvel films.
Meaning that there there isn't a lot that
Marvel is stuffing into guardians the galaxy.
2: People keep asking questions about how
this is going to cross over with the avengers
franchise.
He said that they will meet at some point.
It's really funny how he hems and haws around
that.
I feel like everyone understands where this
is headed.
To Infinity War, giant universe spanning consequences.
At some point the the Avengers will be in
outer space or the guardians will come to
earth.
Logically, the avengers going to outer space
would be more spectacular than the guardians
coming to earth.
Although at some point you'd think that Peter
Quill would return to earth.
But before that he has to find his father
and that's what this film is all about
Second, because the film is all about fathers,
it's not just about Peter Quill's father.
He didn't say this is a film about shitty
fathers, but I think it's implied.
In every superhero movie there's always a
really crappy dad or really awesome dad.
You fall into one or two categories.
A lot of the beats will revolve around Peter
Quill's father, who is J'son of Spartax in
the comics.
He already said that that's not to be the
case movie.
James Gunn's like, nope.
No Jason.
There a couple reasons for that, most being
that he didn't want other new humans in the
film.
Like he wanted Peter Quill to be the only
human.
He wants him to still feel like a unique presence
in the galaxy like being the only human from
earth.
J'son Spartak and the Spartoi Empire look
like they're from earth.
So they're too similar.
Adam Warlock is the highest on everyone's
wish list.
But the problem is is that the Vision looks
a lot like what Adam Warlock would look like
in the film.
So they're probably not to use Adam Warlock
in Guardians of the Galaxy.
Which is a bummer because Adam warlock possesses
the soul gem in the context of the comics.
We have to get the soul gem at some point,
but that's probably going to show up in the
Doctor Strange movie as his Eye of Agamotto.
They did the same thing with Vision and the
Mind Gem.
So they're mixing and matching stuff with
the gems from the comics and the movies.
So expect some changes to the soul gem when
it shows up.
Just remember that when Peter Quill's mother
died in the first film.
She said that, "he
seemed like an angel that came down."
I think the crazy twist would be if the Collector
was his father.
But let's look at the other fathers in the
group.
We have Gamora with Thanos, confirmed shitty
dad.
So obviously the movie is going to push into
that relationship a little bit.
Karen Gillan will be back as Nebula too, complicating
that relationship.
Between the sisters and their dad.
Their very
very evil dad.
And just because the film is about fathers,
doesn't mean that it's about all the Guardian's
fathers.
Remember, Drax the Destroyer's family was
killed by Ronan the Accuser.
He was a father himself, so the film will
deal with that too.
In the comics he had a more direct relationship
with Thanos.
The movie just changed that.
Just to make things a little simpler.
Other big Shocking Twist: He didn't reveal
what Groot was going to look like at the beginning
of the film.
Remember the last time we saw him, he was
dancing baby Groot.
So radical idea here: The Groot that's in
the potted plant.
The little dancing baby
Groot.
That could be "Son of Groot"
So Rocket could now be the surrogate father
of Groot or Groot 2.0, however you want to
think about it.
If that's the case, it would be a big change
from the comics.
Groot has the ability to regrow himself from
the smallest bit of genetic material.
He gets blown up all the time.
When he does, Rocket sticks a little bit of
him in a potted plant.
Pours some water on
him, and he regrows himself.
But it's the same Groot.
When he completely
regrows himself, it's not like his brain patterns
change.
It seems like based on what he's saying, the
Groot we meet in the next film will be the
descendant of the Groot
from
the 1st film.
Even if that's the case, Vin Diesel will still
voice the character.
It's not like he's leaving or anything like
that.
I just really like the idea of Rocket becoming
father of Groot.
Next really big detail: There will be a new
character joining the Guardians of The Galaxy
team.
Like a new Guardian.
Like I said, Peter Quill, going to be the
only human from earth in the film.
So the new character that becomes a Guardian,
will be someone from outer space.
He's given no hints as to who that's going
to be.
Only that it's not going to be anyone that
comes from X-Men IP.
And it's not going to be NOVA.
He did joke and say the Thanos Copter was
the new Guardian.
As much as that's a joke, we could see an
Easter Egg for the Thanos Copter in the film.
And just in case it hasn't been said before,
this film isn't going to be a direct prequel
to Avengers Infinity War.
Just because it comes so close to that film.
In terms of the Marvel Cinematic Universe,
it's the most stand-alone franchise that they
have.
Because it has been so successful.
If it had not made so much money, that wouldn't
be the case.
The idea is, that by connecting all these
titles like you would a big comic book event.
They financially support each other.
Because it's like, "Well if this is connected,
I have to go see it to understand the story
in this OTHER film."
The more successful stuff is, the less that's
a big deal.
It's like "okay, we can just make this movie.
It doesn't have to connect.
People will go see it no matter what.
Age of Ultron is the Stark contrast to that.
It set up all the Phase 3 movies.
Thor Ragnarok, Captain America Civil War,
all that stuff.
So when Guardians 2 ends, the only thing that
it will really be setting up is Guardians
3.
Because it was envisioned as a Trilogy.
Because there's only 1 more Guardians film
before Avengers Infinity War, we're probably
not going to see that 3rd film until Phase
4.
And yes, there is a Phase 4.
I always get a lot of questions about that.
"How many Phases is marvel going to do?"
What's going to happen after Phase 3 and all
the actor's contracts are up?
Some of the actors have already renewed their
contracts.
They didn't say which actors, but some of
the Avengers that started during Phase 1 will
continue to be Avengers in Phase 4.
Marvel will keep doing Phases until they want
to do a big Universe rebooting.
Really, the logical end point for the Marvel
Cinematic Universe before a big reboot would
be Secret Wars.
The battleworld stuff that's going on right
now.
They would just turn that into a film and
use it as a way to reboot all their franchises.
Really the thing I think we need to be talking
about for this movie, is will Peter Quill's
father be a villain in the movie?
In the comics recently his father has become
part of the big Black Vortex storyline.
Which I think a lot of people have been disappointed
with.
But essentially, it's turned his father into
an outright villain.
That's J'Son of Spartax.
He's not going to be in movie, but that doesn't
mean Peter Quill's father in the movie universe
WON'T be a villain.
So here's my big question for you guys, "Do
you want Peter Quill's father to be a villain
in the movie, or do you want him to be a hero?"
Really I think it would be more fun if he
were neutral.
Because he could still be an asshole and help
them.
And that's usually the relationship you see
with people and their fathers in films like
this.
Howard Stark, complete asshole, but he's still
viewed as a hero because he does a lot of
good things.
Probably not the best dad to Tony, which is
why he has so many daddy issues.
Same thing's probably going to happen with
Chris Pratt's character, with Peter Quill.
What I'm probably going to do for my next
Guardians of the Galaxy video is the characters
I want to see become the new Guardian.
Be sure to subscribe to get that.
If there's any other Guardians videos you
guys want to see this summer, just let me
know in the comments.
So here's what's going to happen with the
weekly Marvel giveaway this summer.
I'm going to be doing the same thing for DC
too.
At least once a week, I'm going to do a giveaway
just like I do for Game of Thrones or any
of the other big videos I do.
Like Walking Dead.
So look for those videos on Monday and Tuesday,
I don't know which day what will post, but
it will be whichever first DC video of the
week and which ever first Marvel video of
the week.
It's just like how I do my Game Of Thrones
giveaways in the episode video and announce
the winner in the Q&A the next day.
When we get to comic con, there will probably
be special editions of all those because there
will be so much merch flying around.
So while you guys wait for all that stuff
to post.
You can click here for the latest footage
from Ant-Man and you can click here to learn
all about Mirror Master coming to The Flash
Season 2.
Thank you so much for watching, everybody
let's high five and I'll see you tonight!